[Music]
this is the one at Palm an Ultra Luxury
building in Dubai operated by the
Dorchester apartment prices start at 15
million dollars and go up from there but
what would justify these prices let's go
inside and check it out
this is one of Dubai's most luxurious
residential Towers buyers of the 90
apartments in this building come from
all over the world and they're willing
to pay big bucks for the amenities here
that includes a private beach indoor and
outdoor pools 24-hour concierge gym
sauna private Cinema you name it luxury
real estate has been on a tear in Dubai
ever since the pandemic hit and caused
lockdowns all over the world Dubai
managed with about three weeks of full
lockdown initially but the city soon
after started gradually opening up
returning life back to near normal
within few months
that drove some of the world's
wealthiest to buy homes in Dubai and
some moved their families to the city
but other factors include lower taxes
and a seven-year price slump that made
property in Dubai more affordable than
other Global cities also Russia's
invasion of Ukraine brought in scores of
wealthy Russians looking to Shield their
money from the bite of sanctions Prime
real estate prices shot up more than 70
percent this year outpacing gains in
London and New York for The Wider
housing market in Dubai Prices rose nine
percent and rental rates surged 26 in
the year through September for now data
shows transaction volumes are still
going strong despite Rising interest
rates and worries about global recession
foreign